In this case I want to start with finding the countries that participated in
a given year since it's a litte bit more complicated than simply filtering our
data by year.
And once we see how to select the countries of interest
filtering the years should be quite easy.
In order to find every country that has participated for a given year,
we're going to go back to our aggregation functions that we've defined for
use on our nested object.
We can see here in the agg year function.
Which will get passed leaves, and if you remember, in this case,
it's all of the games for a given year grouped, and
after we compute what we've already found of the sum of the attendance.
And the coordinates to draw,
we can simply group the teams together into an array to return in the end.
D3 actually has a lot of great built in data structures, and
functions to filter and transform data.
In this case we're going to be using d3's built-in set data structure
which functions just like other sets in math or other programming languages.
It's a collection of distinct or unique objects.
It has the property that if you add an element to a set is already contained in
it, it doesn't add a duplicate.
Here we've initialized an empty set, which we
can then iterate through our teams for a given year, adding them one at a time.
To do this, we can use JavaScript's built-in forEach function called on
our leaves array.
ForEach is similar to map, except for
instead of returning an array, as we did when we found our coordinates.
It simply runs an accessor function and
passes every element of our array, one at a time.
In this case, we're not actually returning anything from our for
each, we're only adding team one and team two to our set.
And again, since the set automatically de-duplicates anything, we don't have to
worry about adding teams multiple times, the set takes care of that for us.
So in the end,
the set will represent a collection of unique teams for a given year.
And to pass our teams to our return object, we call .values.
On the teams set, which turns the set of team names,
into an array that we can handle easily in the rest of our code.
Now that we have the teams for a given year,
let's go back to our update function, and put all the pieces together.